the prime minister is poised to make a
common statement
on monday according to the sunday
telegraph which is reporting
that he's going to unveil a covid winter
plan
there is to be a cabinet meeting
tomorrow afternoon a rare sunday
afternoon cabinet meeting or obviously
it will be done remotely the pm
is still isolating in the flat above
number 11.
obviously he is going to confirm the
knockdown will end the national lockdown
in england will
end on the 2nd of december but following
that there is going to they're going to
be tough restrictions
up to just before christmas the
three-tier system will come back in
england
but as medics have said in recent days
they will be strengthened there'll be
some pretty tough rules possibly some
more and more areas going into tier
three
we'll learn which parts of the england
will go into tiers one two and three
later in the week on thursday but the
big news really is that the prime
minister
is planning to update mps on monday
in a statement saying tough restrictions
throughout
throughout december but he will talk
about how families can meet up at
christmas now
no confirmation yet but it's thought
perhaps up to a week
five days or a week or so when relax uh
rules will be
relaxed perhaps from the 22nd to the
28th
of december scientists though are pretty
opposed to that
there is also a rebellion uh being
threatened by conservative mps
this group calling itself the kovid
recovery group
led by former ministers steve baker and
mark
mark harper have written to the prime
minister
threatening a big commons rebellion if
there are tough new restrictions
when the lockdown ends on the 2nd of
december
there is the prime minister is going to
promise votes in the house of commons on
the new restrictions
the other thing people in government are
emphasizing is they want a four nations
approach
so that people can say go and visit
relatives move from england to scotland
or
vice versa to visit relatives over
christmas although ministers are
stressing it will not be
a normal festive period